Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. welcome back to the rest is history we are talking about the jewish revolt which i know tom holland thinks is the wrong title for it because he's going to explain why i mean he's going to explain why it wasn't jewish and maybe why it wasn't a revolt i don't know uh but before we get back into the narrative i just want to say this a few weeks ago tom we did a um a whole series of podcasts about russia and ukraine for the beginning of the war and you said that at one point oh well you know i wonder if anyone's listened to this in russia almost certainly not
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》，我们正在讨论犹太起义，我知道汤姆·霍兰认为这个标题不太对，因为他会解释原因——我的意思是，他会解释为什么这不是“犹太”起义，也可能解释为什么这不是一场“起义”，我不知道，呃，但在我们回到叙事之前，汤姆，我只想说这个：几周前，我们做了一系列关于俄乌战争爆发的播客节目，当时你曾说过，嗯，你知道，我不知道在俄罗斯有没有人听这个，几乎肯定没有
because it's been because of the clampdown on information and so on but actually we have had a message uh i will just call him b because we don't necessarily want to give away who he is. He says he wants to thank us for the recent episodes. For him, a Russian, it was interesting and important. He says it's very important that we understand and the other European listeners understand that the current war is not the Russian people's war, but the war of their president. Millions of us are against this war, he says. He says, in one of your episodes, you've expressed doubts whether Russian people can hear you at all.
因为那里对信息的封锁等等，但实际上我们收到了一条消息，呃，我暂且称他为“B”，因为我们不一定想泄露他的身份。他说他想感谢我们最近的节目。对他来说，一个俄罗斯人，这很有趣也很重要。他说，非常重要的一点是，我们要让其他欧洲听众明白，当前的战争不是俄罗斯人民的战争，而是他们总统的战争。我们数百万人反对这场战争，他说。他说，在你们的一期节目中，你们曾表达过怀疑，不知道俄罗斯人是否能听到你们的声音。
Yes, we can and we do. And we are listening to you through various technological wheezes to find their way around the Russian government's firewall. So, Tom, that's quite inspirational, isn't it? That's quite nice to hear yeah and it's very important to remember that as he says um you know there are plenty of people in russia who are very opposed to what's happening well those brave people who have been arrested at demonstrations and so on braver than i would be 15 years in prison they risk take our hats off to them right let's us um uh move back 2 000 years or just under 2 000 years so we were with brian adams in the summer of 69 and uh vespasian has become emperor the jewish revolt or i know you don't think it is the jewish
是的，我们能听到，我们也在听。我们通过各种技术手段绕过了俄罗斯政府的防火墙来收听你们的节目。所以，汤姆，这相当鼓舞人心，不是吗？听到这个感觉挺好的，是的，而且非常重要的一点是要记住，正如他所说，呃，你知道，俄罗斯有很多人非常反对正在发生的事情。那些在示威活动中被捕的勇敢的人们，比我要勇敢得多——面临15年的监禁，他们冒着风险——让我们向他们脱帽致敬。好了，让我们，呃，把时间拨回2000年前，或者说不到2000年前。所以我们回到了69年的夏天，当时还有乐队“布赖恩·亚当斯”，呃，维斯帕先成为了皇帝，犹太起义，或者我知道你认为这不是犹太……
well jewish is fine but but i think judean is more accurate way judean revolt is in full swing so vespasian presumably tom it must be one of his kind of foreign policy priorities not really foreign policy is it's kind of he would see it as domestic policy that he needs to crack down on this straight away to assert his you know well yeah you might think that actually that's not the case um so soespasian basically has, he's essentially everywhere that's in rebellion has been crushed. The only places that aren't are Jerusalem and a couple of fortresses, one of which is Masada. So Masada was the palace built by Herod on top of the mountain. palace complex which has been occupied by who well we'll maybe come to that later yeah um so vespasian basically he judea is is not now sufficiently important for him to bother with he has much bigger fish to fry so he goes to alexandria and then he goes to rome um he said
嗯，犹太人也可以，但我认为用“犹太地”更准确，犹太地起义正在如火如荼地进行。所以维斯帕先，汤姆，这肯定是他某种程度上的外交政策优先事项吧？其实这不算外交政策，他会认为这是国内政策，他需要立即镇压这场起义，以宣示他的……嗯，对，你可能会这么想，但实际上并非如此。所以，维斯帕先基本上，所有处于叛乱中的地区基本上都被镇压了。唯一没有被镇压的是耶路撒冷和几个要塞，其中之一就是马萨达。马萨达是希律王在山顶建造的宫殿。宫殿综合体，被谁占领了呢？嗯，我们稍后再谈。嗯，所以维斯帕先基本上，犹太地现在对他来说已经不那么重要了，没必要去管它了，他有更重要的事情要处理，所以他去了亚历山大港，然后去了罗马。他说……
he sells for rome in um in the spring of 70 and what he's done is his son, Titus, has been with him, has been commanding one of the legions. And he entrusts the command of the suppression of the conquest of Jerusalem to Titus. And Titus has with him a very, very interesting and perhaps unexpected character, a man called Julius Alexander, who'd been the prefect of Egypt, which is, you know, Dominic, as you'll know, the richest province in the whole Roman Empire. The breadbasket. And so therefore, no senator is allowed to serve as its prefect. So this Julius Alexander is not a senator, but hugely trusted. He's worked his way up through the Roman military, held a number of administrative posts. Now, the thing that's interesting about him is that he is a Judean. And in fact, he is the son of an Alexandrian
他于70年春天启程前往罗马，随行的是他的儿子提图斯，提图斯一直和他在一起，指挥着其中一个军团。他将压制和征服耶路撒冷的指挥权交给了提图斯。提图斯身边有一个非常非常有趣且可能出乎意料的人物，一个叫尤利乌斯·亚历山大的人，他曾担任埃及长官，正如多米尼克你知道的，那是整个罗马帝国最富裕的省份。也就是粮仓。因此，没有参议员可以担任该省长官。所以这个尤利乌斯·亚历山大不是参议员，但极受信任。他通过罗马军队一步步晋升，担任过许多行政职务。现在，关于他最有趣的一点是，他是一个犹太地人。事实上，他是亚历山大里亚一个犹太地人的儿子，
Judean who had paid for the great gates at the Temple of Jerusalem to be silver-plated. So the fact that Titus's deputy is a Judean, I i think is sufficient to complicate the sense that here we have a you know it's it is just romans and jews as the title of our episode suggests and then of course also we you know there is yosef this guy who has um proclaimed that vespasian is so he's totally turned his coat now as he's totally turned his coat yeah, as is Yusuf. He's totally turned his coat. But because I think he feels quite legitimately that God is on the side of the Romans, that Jerusalem is doomed. And therefore, what God wants is for the Judeans to surrender to Rome and to resume their role under Roman rule. So this raises a really interesting question, Tom. The fact that you've got Julius Alexander and you've also got yusuf how much is this a an inter an internecine kind of
这个人曾出资为耶路撒冷圣殿的大门镀银。所以，提图斯的副手是一个犹太地人，我认为这足以让事情变得复杂，打破“这只是罗马人和犹太人之间的冲突”这种简单的看法，正如我们节目的标题所暗示的那样。然后当然还有优素福（约瑟夫斯），这个家伙曾宣称维斯帕先是……所以他现在彻底叛变了，正如尤素福一样，他彻底叛变了。因为我认为他非常合理地认为上帝站在罗马人一边，耶路撒冷注定要灭亡。因此，上帝的意愿是让犹太地人向罗马投降，并恢复他们在罗马统治下的角色。这就引出了一个非常有趣的问题，汤姆。既然你有尤利乌斯·亚历山大，还有优素福，这在多大程度上是一场犹太地人内部的……
judean thing i mean there must be quite a lot of judeans who think god i wish the revolt had never happened who are these clowns who are yeah absolutely i suppose it's impossible for us at this distance to have any sense of the numbers or the proportion, presumably? Well, we can say that it spans from high to low. So from high, Herod Agrippa is also riding with Titus and also going is Berenice, his sister, who has begun an affair with Titus. So Berenice is not only in Titus's train, but actually in his bed, probably by this stage. But we also know that there are lots of people in Jerusalem who are frantic to get out and to surrender. And so that passage from the Gospels that you quoted, Jesus was saying, get out. There are lots of people who do try and do that. The problem is that there are enough people in Jerusalem who know that they have no way out. They know that
内部冲突？我的意思是，肯定有很多犹太地人心里在想：天哪，我真希望这场起义从未发生过。这些小丑究竟是谁？嗯，完全是这样。我想，在这个距离上，我们根本不可能了解具体的人数或比例吧？嗯，我们可以说，这涵盖了从社会上层到底层的各个阶层。从上层来看，希律·阿格里帕也随提图斯同行，同行的还有他的妹妹贝勒尼基，她已经开始与提图斯交往。所以贝勒尼基不仅在提图斯的随行人员中，而且在这个阶段很可能已经上了他的床。但我们也知道，耶路撒冷有很多人急于逃出去投降。所以你引用的福音书中的那段话，耶稣当时在说，快逃。确实有很多人试图这样做。问题是，耶路撒冷有足够多的人知道他们已经无路可逃。他们知道，
they are going to suffer terrible death if they surrender because of the role that they've played, either in the original revolt or in the annihilation of the Roman legions at Beth Haron. And they're the ones with the weapons. And so they are the ones who are in a position to determine policy. So they sort of double down, basically. Yeah, they double down. And so when the Romans arrive in front of Jerusalem, Titus has four legions, large quantities of auxiliary soldiers, huge quantities of artillery. He waits for the Judeans to surrender. They don't.
如果他们投降，将会遭受可怕的死亡，因为他们在最初的起义中，或者在伯和仑歼灭罗马军团的行动中扮演过角色。而他们手里有武器。所以他们是有权决定政策的人。所以他们基本上是孤注一掷了。是的，他们孤注一掷。因此，当罗马人兵临耶路撒冷城下时，提图斯拥有四个军团、大量的辅助部队以及数量庞大的炮兵。他等待犹太地人投降。他们没有投降。
There are lots who want to surrender but the people in charge the people with the ability to decide what policy should be are you know they have waded in blood so far that you know there's no going back quite a familiar pattern yeah so so titus uh launches the attack um so where what what year are we now are we so we're now we're now in spring of 70. And Jerusalem is a very, very hard nut to crack. And the siege of Jerusalem is the bloodiest, most brutal, the most challenging that a Roman army has faced since the destruction of Carthage almost two centuries previously. And the reason for that, as I said, is that there are basically three great lines of walls that have to be breached. So there's an outer wall in the north and then there's kind of inner wall and then a wall kind of in between them.
有很多人想投降，但掌权的人——那些有能力决定政策走向的人——双手已经沾满了鲜血，以至于没有回头路了。这真是个熟悉的模式。是的，所以提图斯发动了进攻。那么，我们现在是什么年份？我们现在是70年的春天。耶路撒冷是一块非常非常难啃的骨头。对耶路撒冷的围城战是自近两个世纪前迦太基被毁以来，罗马军队面临的最血腥、最残酷、最具挑战性的战役。正如我所说，原因在于基本上有三道巨大的城墙必须被攻破。北方有一道外墙，然后是一道内墙，然后它们之间还有一道墙。
You have a fortress called the Antonia, which had been the Roman military fortress. And that is next to the Great Rock of the Temple, which is also basically a fortress. So to capture Jerusalem, you have to go through three walls and you have to capture the Antonia and you have to capture the temple. And even then, there's the great palace of Herod. That's also been fortified, so that too has to be taken. So it's a very, very tough ask. But the Romans are not the elite fighting force that they are for nothing. They smash through the outer wall.
你们有一个叫安东尼亚的要塞，它曾经是罗马的军事要塞。它靠近圣殿大要塞，而圣殿本身基本上也是一座要塞。所以要攻占耶路撒冷，你必须突破三道城墙，你必须攻占安东尼亚，你必须攻占圣殿。即便如此，还有希律王的宏伟宫殿。它也被加固了，所以也必须攻克它。所以这是一个非常非常艰巨的任务。但罗马人并非浪得虚名，他们是精锐战斗力量。他们冲破了外墙。
They invade from the north again, as Gallus had done. And they occupy the whole of this new town, which had been built north of the old central city. And they occupy it and having done that titus arrays all his legions in full battle honor um armor shining uh horses lined up auxiliaries lined up standards glittering and gleaming with the aim of intimidating the judeans to surrender and i think still at this point his aim is essentially to try and get back to the status quo. He wants to get back. So he wants to round up the ringleaders to kill them, to execute them.
他们再次从北方入侵，就像加卢斯曾经做过的那样。他们占领了这座建在旧中央城市以北的新城区的全部区域。他们占领了这里，随后提图斯让所有军团全副武装列阵——整齐的铠甲闪闪发光，战马列队排开，辅助部队整齐列队，军旗熠熠生辉，目的是恐吓犹太地人让他们投降。而且我认为在这个阶段，他的主要目的基本上还是试图恢复现状。他想恢复原状。所以他想抓捕那些为首的人，把他们杀掉，处决他们。
Punishment will certainly be inflicted. But essentially, he's got Herod Agrippa with him in his train. He probably wants to return to a situation where Herod Agrippa can administer the temple, where there are kind of tame priests installed, where once again, Jerusalem can kind of provide a center for Roman administration over the region. He doesn't want to obliterate the entire city. That would raise issues that at this stage, he doesn't want to have to face. But the Judeans continue to resist. Jerusalem does not surrender. And so what Titus then does is he moves in for the kill.
惩罚肯定会实施。但基本上，他的随行人员中有希律·阿格里帕。他可能希望恢复这样一种局面：希律·阿格里帕可以管理圣殿，那里安插了一些听话的祭司，耶路撒冷可以再次成为罗马对该地区行政管理的中心。他不想彻底摧毁整座城市。那会带来他现阶段不想面对的问题。但犹太地人继续抵抗。耶路撒冷没有投降。于是提图斯接下来采取的行动就是发起总攻。
And he does this in two ways. The first is he builds a huge, great wall around Jerusalem to block everybody in. And that's what Jesus alludes to in his prophecy. That's worrying. When you've been holding out against a siege and the besiegers start to wall you in, then you know something terrible is coming. And by this point, all the kind of the woods, the parks for which Jerusalem had been famous have all been leveled for around 10 miles to build siege engines, to build ramps and to build this wall, which is completed in five days. And from now on, it's becoming increasingly difficult for people to forage food, to forage for food or to launch attacks or to um still more to try and escape and anyone who is captured what the romans do is they what what trees remain are planted in the kind of the rubble of the old of the new town that the romans have
他通过两种方式做到这一点。首先，他在耶路撒冷周围修建了一堵又高又大的墙，把所有人封锁在里面。这就是耶稣在预言中暗示的。这很让人担忧。当你一直在苦苦坚守围城，而围城者开始筑墙把你围起来时，你就知道可怕的事情要来了。到这个时候，耶路撒冷原本闻名遐迩的所有树林和公园都被砍伐一空，方圆大约10英里内的树木都被夷为平地，用来制造攻城器械、修建攻城坡道以及建造这堵在五天内就完工的墙。从现在开始，人们觅食、寻找食物、发动进攻、或者更不用说试图逃跑，变得越来越困难。任何被俘的人，罗马人都会……
occupied and they are crucified there and we're told that um told that the legionaries to amuse themselves, and because they're so full of hate for the resistors, you know, among the kind of the heat and the stench of blood and dust, that they tie their prisoners in increasingly inventive and cruel ways. I know I've already, I mentioned this in the crucifixion episode. So these crucifixions are, you know, designed to be as grotesque as possible. And so the defenders looking out from their walls, see this great forest of their compatriots kind of writhing and twisting, nailed or bound to trees. I mean, kind of horrible, gruesome spectacle. And this is um uh women and children as well as men or if they they have no left probably men it's probably fighters yeah probably men so what's happened to the to the women and children well they're trying to get out so one of the things that um that happens is that people swallow their gold and then go out and then they kind of you know they have a a dump and take the gold out from the,
他们把剩下的大树种在罗马人占领的新城区的废墟中，并将战俘们钉在树上处死。我们听说，军团士兵们为了自娱自乐，也是因为他们对抵抗者充满了仇恨——在那种酷热、血腥和尘土的气味中——他们以越来越富有创造力和残酷的方式绑缚他们的囚犯。我知道我已经提过了，我在十字架受刑的那集里提到过。所以这些钉十字架的方式旨在尽可能地怪诞。因此，防守者从城墙上向外望去，看到这片巨大的“森林”，到处都是他们的同胞在被钉在或绑在树上时痛苦地扭动和挣扎。我的意思是，这是一种极其可怕、可怖的景象。这也是……男女老少皆有，还是说只剩下男人了？可能主要是男人，可能是战斗人员，是的，可能都是男人。那么妇女和儿童怎么样了呢？嗯，他们在设法逃出去。发生的事情之一就是，人们把黄金吞进肚子里，然后逃出去，接着他们排便，把黄金从粪便里取出来。
from the poo. That's a nice image. But the various Syrian auxiliaries discover that they're doing that. And so whenever they get prisons, they slit open the stomach to try and feed, to grab the gold out. So that's an added complication that people face. And so increasingly people just stay inside the city and,
这是一个美好的画面。但叙利亚的各种辅助部队发现他们在这么做。所以每当他们抓到俘虏，就会剖开他们的肚子，试图把黄金掏出来。所以这是人们面临的又一个复杂情况。因此，越来越多的人干脆待在城里，
you know, people are beginning to starve because the fighters, the people who are leading the resistance, are monopolizing the food. And so people just start to die in the streets. And their bodies get tipped over the walls and they start kind of littering the various ravines. So presumably huge dysentery, cholera or whatever. Yeah, it's unspeakable. The conditions are unspeakable.
人们开始挨饿，因为战斗人员——那些领导抵抗的人——垄断了食物。于是人们开始死在街上。他们的尸体被抛过城墙，开始堆积在各个沟壑里。所以可以想象，会有严重的痢疾、霍乱之类的疫情。是的，这难以言表。那里的状况简直难以言表。
But the Judeans, the fighters continue to resist um the titus orders the antonia to be stormed the great fortress uh and this again is a kind of brutal exhausting process so great um great ramps are built uh the judeans have tunneled underneath them. They kind of set these tunnels on fire. The ramps collapse. Titus orders them to build it again. The wall comes down. The Romans storm it. And now they've got to get into the temple.
但犹太地人，那些战斗人员仍在继续抵抗。提图斯下令强攻安东尼亚，这座巨大的要塞。这又是一个残酷且令人精疲力竭的过程。他们建造了巨大的坡道，而犹太地人在坡道下方挖了地道。他们点燃了这些地道。坡道坍塌了。提图斯下令重新建造。城墙倒塌了。罗马人发起强攻。现在他们必须进入圣殿了。
And again, Titus levels the Antonia. They build the ramps up on the temple, build it on the other side of the wall as well. And finally, Titus decides that he's you know he's had enough so they set fire to the the uh to the great gates these gates that have been silver plated by his deputy's father the silver melts the wood implodes the fire starts to spread and to um it lights up the colonnades that surround the great central the great outer court of the temple and the legions are able to force their way in, but the Judeans are still holding out in the inner sanctuary. And now Titus has to decide what he's going to do about the temple. Is he going to incinerate it or is he
接着，提图斯夷平了安东尼亚。他们在圣殿上修建坡道，也在城墙的另一侧建造。最后，提图斯决定他受够了，于是他们放火焚烧了宏伟的大门——这些大门曾由他副手的父亲贴上银箔。银子融化了，木头内爆，大火开始蔓延，点燃了环绕着圣殿大外院的柱廊，军团得以强行突入，但犹太地人仍然在内殿死守。现在提图斯必须决定如何处理圣殿。他是要将其烧为灰烬，还是
going to try and spare it? And this is hugely contested because the one account we have of it is written by a Judean. And I don't think I'm giving away any spoilers when I say that it's Yusuf, who in due course will go on to become a Roman citizen and take the name of Josephus. And Josephus tells us that Titus wanted to spare it. But Josephus is trying to square two very different things. One is he wants to keep the favor of Titus, and the other, he wants to explain how it is that the temple came to be destroyed, because he remains a very devout Judean. And so this idea that Titus wanted to spare the temple, but that God had destined it for destruction is very, very important to him. So whether that's actually what happened or not, we don't know. One thing that perhaps counters the idea
试图放过它？这引起了巨大的争议，因为我们关于此事仅有的记载是由一位犹太地人撰写的。当我剧透说这个人就是优素福（约瑟夫斯）时，我想我并没有泄露太多惊喜，他日后将成为罗马公民并改名为弗拉维奥·约瑟夫斯。约瑟夫斯告诉我们，提图斯本想放过圣殿。但约瑟夫斯在试图平衡两件非常不同的事情。一方面，他想保持提图斯的青睐；另一方面，他想解释圣殿为何会被摧毁，因为他依然是一个非常虔诚的犹太地人。因此，“提图斯本想放过圣殿，但上帝注定要将其毁灭”这种观点对他的论述至关重要。所以这究竟是不是事实，我们不得而知。有一个因素也许反驳了“圣殿是被错误地点燃的”这一说法——
that the temple was set on fire by mistake, which is what Josephus says happens, is that the treasure of the temple is taken out and kept. And how would you do that if the temple was on fire? Tom, there's a question from one of our listeners, Stephen Clark, history teacher. He says, it's the Raiders of the Lost Ark question. What happened to the Ark of the Covenant and the other sacred objects that were in the Jerusalem temple?
约瑟夫斯称这是意外发生的事情——那就是圣殿的财宝被拿走并保存了下来。如果圣殿正在燃烧，你怎么能做到这一点呢？汤姆，我们的听众之一，历史教师史蒂芬·克拉克（Stephen Clark）提出了一个问题。他说，这是一个“夺宝奇兵”式的问题。约柜和耶路撒冷圣殿里的其他圣物去哪儿了？
Are they in an American warehouse somewhere in the Midwest? Well, the Ark of the Covenant is not there, as far as we know. It kind of vanishes with the Babylonian sack of Jerusalem. Okay. But there's the great kind of the menorah. There's a great table all made of gold. These are treasures that are taken. And so one implication of that might be that the legions had gone in,
它们是在中西部某个美国的仓库里吗？据我们所知，约柜并不在那里。它随着巴比伦人洗劫耶路撒冷而消失了。好吧。但那里有巨大的金灯台。还有一张全金打造的大桌子。这些都是被掠夺的财宝。因此，这可能意味着军团已经闯了进去，
they had stripped the temple, and then they'd incinerated it. I mean, the honest answer is we will never know. We cannot know. So the destruction of the temple, I mean, this is an absolute body blow, not just to the defenders, but to every Judean, because this is the holiest place for Judeans on the face of the earth. So the horror of it is hard to overemphasize. But even after its destruction, even when it's just a kind of smoking black and rubble, the Judeans continue the fight. They withdraw to Herod's palace and it takes another month for that to be taken. And then once that has been taken, Titus orders the entire city to be
他们洗劫了圣殿，然后将其焚为灰烬。老实说，我们永远不会知道。我们无法得知。因此，圣殿的毁灭，对防御者以及每一个犹太地人来说，都是一记沉重的打击，因为这是地球上面对犹太地人而言最神圣的地方。因此，这种恐惧怎么强调都不为过。但即使在圣殿被毁之后，即使它只剩下一片冒烟的黑色瓦砾，犹太地人仍在继续战斗。他们撤退到希律王的宫殿，又花了一个月的时间才攻克那里。一旦攻克，提图斯下令将整座城市
destroyed except for a stretch of wall and three of the great towers so that people in future ages would be able to look at it and be able to gauge the scale of what it was that the Romans had done in taking this great and famous city. But everything else is absolutely flattened. And where do the people go who lived there? Or are they all dead? They're enslaved. So they are either dead or they're dead. Just taken to slave markets and traded. Yeah, so the best looking, the tallest, the most handsome captives are taken to Rome to adorn Titus's triumph. And the rest are sold to the slave markets.
彻底摧毁，只留下了一段城墙和三座宏伟的塔楼，以便后世的人们能够看到它，并能够衡量罗马人在攻克这座宏伟而著名的城市时所做事情的规模。但除此之外的一切都被彻底夷为平地。那么，曾经住在那里的人去哪儿了？还是说他们都死了？他们被奴役了。所以他们要么死了，要么……就是死了。只是被带到奴隶市场进行买卖。是的，所以那些外表最好、最高大、最英俊的俘虏被带到罗马，来为提图斯的凯旋游行增添光彩。其余的人则被卖到了奴隶市场。
But this is not the end of the revolt though, Tom, right? No, so Titus goes back, having done his stuff. And whereas previously there hadn't been a legion installed in Jerusalem, now a legion is plonked absolutely on the heart of what had been Jerusalem. So that's one of the reasons why the wall is kept, so it can serve as a kind of outer ring for the legionary base. And it's the 10th legion, which has absolutely has an absolute kind of crack it's it's it's absolutely kind of an elite legion yeah um and order is you know it's judea is definitely
但汤姆，这并不是起义的结束，对吧？是的，提图斯在办完这些事情后回去了。此前耶路撒冷并没有驻扎军团，而现在，一个军团被直接安插在了曾是耶路撒冷的核心地带。这也是保留城墙的原因之一，这样它就可以作为军团基地的外环。这是第十军团，这是一支绝对的王牌精锐军团，绝对的王牌……
at this point constituted as a province and the responsibility rests on the uh the guy given command of this new province to crush the last remaining holdouts. And the very last holdout famously is Masada. So that's Herod's Palace. That was on the rock. Yeah. Yeah. So that's Herod's Palace.
是的，犹太地在此时绝对被建制为一个行省，责任落在了被指派指挥这个新行省的将领身上，去消灭最后残存的抵抗力量。而最后一个著名的抵抗据点就是马萨达。那是希律王的宫殿。它在山顶上。是的。那就是希律王的宫殿。
And that is very, very difficult to take, but the Romans take it. How? How did they take it? They sort of scale the mountain well according to josephus who was not there right so again this massively complicates our our ability to know what actually happened supposedly they build a great ramp i mean you know as they had done in jerusalem but this is on an even larger scale uh and the story goes that um
那个地方非常非常难攻克，但罗马人还是攻下了它。怎么攻下的？他们是怎么攻下的？他们算是爬上了这座山。嗯，根据约瑟夫斯的说法——他当时并不在场，对吧？所以这再次极大复杂化了我们了解实际情况的能力。据称他们修建了一个巨大的坡道——我的意思是，就像他们在耶路撒冷做的那样——但这次规模更大。而且据说，
the uh the rebels on the top when they see that Mossad is doomed to fall or commit suicide rather than be taken. Yeah, that's the one thing that most people know about the Jewish revolt, I would say, is that the last defenders kill themselves. And how true do you think that is? Well, so how true is any of this? I mean, the basic outlines i think are definitely true um you know clearly judea does blaze into revolt yeah clearly jerusalem is destroyed clearly masada is captured uh and there is the evidence of josephus's record he writes a history i'm presuming there's archaeology yeah yeah so there's archaeology both at Jotapata, where Josephus had been taken prisoner, and at Masada.
山顶上的叛军看到马萨达注定要陷落时，便集体自杀，而不是被俘。是的，关于犹太起义，大多数人知道的一点就是，最后的捍卫者自杀了。你认为这有多大程度是真实的？嗯，这里面的真实性到底有多少呢？我的意思是，基本轮廓我认为绝对是真实的。犹太地确实爆发了起义，耶路撒冷显然被摧毁了，马萨达显然被攻陷了，而且有约瑟夫斯的历史记录为证，他写了一部历史。我猜还有考古证据吧？是的，约瑟夫斯被俘的约塔帕塔（Jotapata）和马萨达都有考古发现。
The evidence is intriguing and fascinating and being done. So how is it that Josephus comes to write what he writes? Because it's not at all obvious that a Judean would write an account of this terrible event. And why is it that we know so much about this revolt? And there are three basic reasons for that, I think. The first is that this revolt is not cast by the Flavians as a revolt. It's incredibly important to Vespasian and indeed to Titus, both of whom are kind of upstarts. They have no background. There's nothing about them that would ever have marked them out as potential Caesars. That's why Nero had originally entrusted Vespasian with the command. What they can do is say, well, Vespasian can say, I am a proper
这些证据引人入胜且充满魅力，并且正在不断发掘中。那么，约瑟夫斯是怎么写出他那些文字的呢？因为一个犹太地人去写关于这场可怕事件的记述，并不是一件显而易见的事。为什么我们对这场起义了解得这么多？我认为主要有三个基本原因。首先，弗拉维奥家族并没有将这场起义定性为一场起义。这对维斯帕先和提图斯来说都极其重要，他们两人都是暴发户。他们没有什么背景。他们没有任何地方能让他们成为潜在的凯撒。这就是为什么尼禄最初将指挥权委托给维斯帕先的原因。他们能做的是宣称——维斯帕先可以宣称——我是一个正统的
imperator. Imperator, the word we translate as empire, can also be translated as a general who has prevailed on a battlefield. So Vespasian is a proper Roman in that sense. He has won a great victory. And that's why he and Titus are awarded a triumph, which is this kind of great procession through the streets of Rome, where you have conquered an enemy and brought that enemy in. A sort of worthy enemy, like Cleopatra or like Pyrrhus or great figures from the past. Yes. So like Cleopatra, but not Antony. So Augustus had celebrated a triumph over Cleopatra, but not Antony, because you cannot celebrate a triumph over fellow Romans. So Vespasian's great triumph is his victory in the civil war. That is what has led him to be emperor. But he can't celebrate that, because that is absolutely not the done thing. Now, the problem for Vespasian and Titus is that actually, you can only celebrate a triumph
统帅（Imperator）。Imperator这个我们翻译为帝国的词，也可以翻译为在战场上获胜的将军。所以从这个意义上讲，维斯帕先是一个地地道道的罗马人。他赢得了一场伟大的胜利。这就是为什么他和提图斯被授予凯旋式（triumph），这是一场穿过罗马街道的宏伟游行，在游行中你征服了敌人并将敌人带回。一种值得尊重的敌人，比如克利奥帕特拉（埃及艳后）或皮洛士，或是过去的历史伟人。是的。就像克利奥帕特拉，但不是安东尼。所以屋大维曾庆祝过对克利奥帕特拉的凯旋，但没有针对安东尼，因为你不能对同胞罗马人庆祝凯旋。因此，维斯帕先的伟大凯旋是他在内战中的胜利。正是这一点让他成为了皇帝。但他不能庆祝这个，因为那绝对是犯了大忌。现在，维斯帕先和提图斯面临的问题是，实际上，你只能庆祝凯旋，
if you have conquered an enemy that had not previously been a part of the empire the judeans had been inside the empire hadn't they absolutely had they absolutely had and so this is a huge problem for the flavians and so they bring the full weight of their propaganda um expertise to bear on the problem which they do absolutely brilliantly so one thing they do the the triumph they they big it up massively. So they pretend that the Judean captives that they're parading through the streets are people who have never been a part, you know, they'd never belonged to the empire. also parade large quantities of treasure from the the entire east so all kinds of things that had not come from judea right like kind of rare animals great carpets with figurative illustrations which obviously you know no judean yeah would have had um all kinds of things like that uh and they even parade ships implying you know a bit like uh they fought battles. They kind of fought the equivalent of, yes, of the great naval battle that Augustus had won at Actium.
如果你征服了一个以前不属于帝国一部分的敌人。而犹太地人已经在帝国境内了，不是吗？绝对是的，他们绝对是的。所以这对弗拉维奥家族来说是个大问题，于是他们将全部的宣传专业知识投入到解决这个问题上，而且他们做得极其出色。他们做的一件事是，对凯旋式进行了大肆渲染。他们假装那些在街上游行的犹太地人俘虏是从未属于帝国的人。他们还游行展示了来自整个东方的巨额财宝，比如各种并非来自犹太地的东西，如罕见的动物、带有具象插画的华丽地毯（显然没有任何犹太地人会拥有），各种诸如此类的东西。
There had been no naval battles. The most there had been, the Romans had chased some rebels down to the Lake of Galilee and kind of gone out in fishing boats to kill them all. So the Sea of Galilee was dyed blood. A fishing boat would look red but that's it so it's massively massively over inflated they also issue a constant stream of coins with the the phrase udair captor on it so judea has been taken captive and judea is portrayed as a barbarian
他们甚至还展示了船只，暗示……有点像他们打过仗。他们进行了一场类似于屋大维在阿克提姆赢得的伟大海战的战役。实际上根本没有海战。最多也就是罗马人把一些叛兵追到加利利湖，然后坐着渔船出去把他们全杀了。所以加利利湖被染红了。一艘渔船看起来可能会是红色的，但仅此而已。所以这是被极其夸大、极度夸大的。他们还不断发行硬币，上面印有“Judaear capta”（犹太地被俘）的字样，因此犹太地被描绘成一个在树下哭泣的蛮族
woman weeping underneath a tree and this is a kind of standard image which is done to promote the annexation of previously uncorked peoples. Yeah, they did that when they defeated Cleopatra, didn't they? They did, yes. Egypto-Copter. But they haven't captured Judea
女性，这是一个标准的形象，用来宣传对以前未被征服的民族的吞并。是的，他们在击败克利奥帕特拉时也这么做过，对吧？是的，他们确实这么做了，“Egypto capta”（埃及被俘）。但他们并没有俘获犹太地，
because it was part of the empire. So, Dominic, this is the intriguing thing is that a few decades ago, a coin collector walked in to the numismatists and showed a coin that had been in the collection for quite a while. And on that was the phrase, Judea recepter, Judea retaken. And nobody had any idea that this coin had ever been minted. And the reason for that is that obviously it was done by an overenthusiastic, but ignorant mint.
因为它是帝国的一部分。所以，多米尼克，有趣的是，几十年前，一个钱币收藏家走进钱币学专家的店里，展示了一枚在收藏中存放了相当长时间的硬币。上面印着“Judaea recepta”（犹太地收复）的字样。在此之前，没有人知道这枚硬币曾被铸造过。原因在于，这显然是由一个过于热心但无知的造币厂制作的。
You hadn't realized that you were not meant to be broadcasting that message and so you know this is absolutely unique it's the only example of it and there was um an inscription found on a triumphal arch that had stood by the the um circus maximus the great chariot stadium where titus basically says that he's the first person ever to have captured Jerusalem, which would obviously have come as news to Nebuchadnezzar or Pompey the Great. I mean, people know that Judea had been a province. But they willingly suspend their belief because it's so crucial to Flavian status and propaganda. And so the fact that the Judeans have been defeated and they've become enshrined as the enemies destroyed by the Flavians is fundamental to the establishment of this regime. So that's basically for them,
他们没有意识到自己不应该散布这个信息，所以这是绝无仅有的，是唯一的例子。在一个曾矗立在大竞技场（Circus Maximus）——那个大型战车竞技场——旁边的凯旋门上发现了一个铭文，提图斯在上面基本上声称他是历史上第一个攻占耶路撒冷的人。这显然会对尼布甲尼撒或庞培大帝是个新闻。我的意思是，人们知道犹太地一直是一个行省。但他们自愿选择不去相信真相，因为这对弗拉维奥家族的地位和宣传至关重要。因此，犹太地人被打败，并被塑造成被弗拉维奥家族消灭的敌人，这构成了这个政权建立的基础。所以基本上对他们来说，
Tom, what defeating Cleopatra was for Augustus' sort of foundational myth, a conquest myth. Yeah. And so Augustus celebrates his emergence as Caesar by sponsoring Virgil to write the Aeneid and so on. What the Flavians do is they act as patrons for Josephus, this guy who had been a commander against them, who had hailed Vespasian, you know, as the king who had come out of Judea, and who now writes a series of history. So he writes a history of the war, he writes a history of the entire history of the Judeans, he writes a biography, an autobiography of himself, and he writes a defense of the Judeans and their God and their practices against a pagan critic. So Tom, in many ways, I would say he's come out of quite badly from
汤姆，这就像击败克利奥帕特拉对屋大维的建国神话或征服神话一样。是的。所以屋大维通过赞助维吉尔写《埃涅阿斯纪》来庆祝他作为凯撒的崛起。而弗拉维奥家族所做的，则是充当约瑟夫斯的赞助人——这个曾经与他们对抗的指挥官，曾欢呼维斯帕先为“从犹太地走出来的国王”，而现在他撰写了一系列历史著作。所以他写了一部战争史，写了一部关于犹太地人整段历史的著作，写了自己的自传，并针对一个异教批评家撰写了一部为犹太地人及其上帝和习俗辩护的著作。所以汤姆，从很多方面来说，我觉得他在这个播客里显得挺糟糕的，
this podcast because he seems a bit of a weasel. I mean, he's basically abandoned all his former cause, thrown his lot in and become a Flavian propagandist. Yeah. So this is the image of him, that he's a sinister turncoat and a coward who has just jumped ship. I think this is incredibly unfair. Okay. He is from a class of person in Jerusalem who did not want to rebel against the Romans. He bravely holds out at Jotapata, but when he gets stormed, he thinks, well, I never really believed in this in the first place. I think that we should be siding with Rome. He sees Rome as the agent of God. He finds no contradiction whatsoever in being a dutiful Judean, dutiful to his God and dutiful to Caesar. And the histories that he writes, even though they are incredibly self-aggrandizing, I mean, he's unbelievably
因为他看起来有点像个卑鄙小人。我的意思是，他基本上背叛了自己以前所有的事业，投靠了对方，成为了弗拉维奥家族的宣传机器。是的。所以这就是他的形象——一个阴险的叛徒和懦夫，见风使舵。我认为这极其不公平。好吧。他来自耶路撒冷的一个阶层，那个阶层本来就不想与罗马人反叛。他在约塔帕塔英勇坚守，但当那里被攻陷时，他心想，好吧，我其实从一开始就不相信这个。我认为我们应该站在罗马一边。他将罗马视为上帝的代理人。他发现做一个尽职尽责的犹太地人、对他的上帝尽职、对凯撒尽职，这三者之间没有任何矛盾。他写的历史，尽管极度自我吹嘘——我的意思是，他自负得难以置信，甚至到了滑稽的程度。
conceited, kind of comically so. They're also quite brave. Because what happens in the wake of the destruction of the temple and Vespasian's triumph is that it's decided not to rebuild the temple. And therefore, the priesthood will not be reconstituted. And therefore, a whole new way of ministering the region has to be put in place. And what that in turn means is that it's not just the Judeans who were cast as rebels, but the entire kind of framework of their belief that is seen as having been found wanting. And what had happened during the civil war in Rome in 69 is that their great temple, the temple of Jupiter up on the Capitol had been burnt. And so what the Flavians do and they're short of money, just as Nero had been, is that the tax, the money that Judeans
它们其实也相当勇敢。因为在圣殿被毁和维斯帕先凯旋之后发生的事情是，人们决定不重建圣殿。因此，祭司阶层将不会被重组。因此，必须建立一种全新的区域管理方式。而这反过来意味着，不仅犹太地人被视为叛军，连他们信仰的整个框架也被认为是有缺陷的。在69年罗马内战期间发生的事情是，他们伟大的圣殿——卡皮托利山上朱庇特的圣殿——被烧毁了。所以弗拉维奥家族采取的做法是——他们当时缺钱，就像尼禄一样——犹太地人以前为耶路撒冷圣殿贡献的税款，现在必须用来资助重建卡皮托利山上的圣殿。随之而来的还有……约瑟夫斯针对异教批评家撰写为犹太地人辩护的著作的原因之一，是因为你开始遭遇……嗯，我想你可以……我的意思是，这是后来许多反犹太主义攻击的前身。约瑟夫斯能做这件事是很勇敢的。
had previously contributed towards the temple in Jerusalem, they now have to pay it to fund the rebuilding of the temple on the Capitol. And that is accompanied by... One of the reasons why Josephus writes his defense of the Judeans against the pagan critic is that you're starting to get... Well, I suppose you could... I mean, it's a kind of precursor of a lot of anti-Semitic attacks that will be to come. And this is brave of Josephus to do this.
他本不必这么做。所以他在为自己的人民挺身而出。人们说犹太地人反罗马或不属于罗马。是的，他们反罗马，他们的上帝很荒谬，他们的风俗很荒谬，他们是根深蒂固的叛军，他们孤傲清高，不想与其他人有任何瓜葛。许多针对犹太人的辱骂直到今天仍然是主流。而且这是历史上第一次由帝国资助的。这以前从未发生过。
You know, he doesn't have to do it. So he's sticking up for his people. People saying the Judeans are anti-Roman or un-Roman. Yeah, they're anti-Roman, that their God is ridiculous, that their customs are ridiculous, that they're kind of inveterate rebels, that they're standoffish, that they want to have nothing to do with other people. A lot of the kind of abuse of Jews that is still kind of mainstream to this day. And it's imperially sponsored for the first time. This hadn't previously happened.
但由于犹太地起义对弗拉维奥政权建立的重要性，这种情况发生了。我不认为约瑟夫斯是个懦夫。我的意思是，我认为他写下这些东西是非常非常勇敢的。关于娱乐，我们告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及提前购买现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你刚才提到了犹太起义的重要性。所以我们收到了很多关于这个的问题。
But because of the importance of the Judean revolt to the founding of the Flavian regime, it does. And I don't think Josephus was in any way a coward. I mean, I think he was very, very brave to write what he did. and on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. You just said a second ago the importance of the Jewish revolt. So we've had lots of questions about this.
马克·伍德豪斯（Mark Woodhouse）问，犹太起义和……我们收到了很多关于此的问题。马克·伍德豪斯问，犹太起义和其他起义有什么区别？带着对天主教的思考，犹太起义与罗马人面临的其他叛乱之间是否存在质的区别？在多大程度上，这场叛乱的地位被弗拉维奥家族的宣传完全夸大了？还是说，你会觉得这只是罗马帝国经常发生的事情？帝国不同地区每隔5年、10年或20年就会发生一次抗税起义。
Mark Woodhouse, what's the difference between the Jewish revolts and we've had lots of questions about this. Mark Woodhouse, what's the difference between the Jewish revolts and other revolts? Thoughtfully Catholic, was there a qualitative difference between the Jewish revolts and other rebellions that the Romans faced? To what extent is this something, well, has the place of this rebellion been completely inflated by flavor and propaganda? Or actually, would you say this is the kind of thing that happens in the Roman Empire? Every 5, 10, 20 years in a different part of the empire, there's a tax revolt.
人们揭竿而起。他们不得不派军队去平息。然后所有其他的起义都被完全遗忘了。但唯独这场被人们铭记。那么，这段历史的记忆及其重要性是否被弗拉维奥家族夸大了？绝对是的。是否也被另一群对借此宣扬特定观点感兴趣的人夸大了？是的，当然是。而这些人，当然就是基督徒。因为甚至在耶路撒冷被毁之前，你看看保罗的著作。
People kick off. They have to send in troops to quell it. And then all the others are completely forgotten. But this is the one that's remembered. Well, has the memory of this been, and the significance of it being inflated by the flavians absolutely has it been inflated by another group of people who have a stake in putting a particular spin on this episode yes it has and those people of of course, are the Christians. Because even before the destruction of Jerusalem, you look in the writings of Paul.
在那里，你会有一种感觉：由于基督已经向上帝献出了完美的牺牲，因此不再需要犹太地习俗所规定的在圣殿中进行的牺牲。而且此外，圣殿已经被基督徒信徒的群体所取代。教会现在就是新的圣殿。这些观点在圣殿被洗劫之前就已经存在了。所以圣殿随后被毁这一事实，对新兴的基督教社群来说，是绝对的证据，证明这种观点是正确的，证明上帝已经对圣殿建制进行了衡量，发现它有亏欠。这就是为什么从长远来看，约瑟夫斯的著作能够流传下来。因为基督徒的原因，它们被基督徒保存了下来，因为它们对于支持这种基督教观念至关重要——即基本上教会已经取代了圣殿，成为上帝关怀的焦点。等等，汤姆，假设……呃，你知道，君士坦丁大帝，他是众多……嗯，人们在试用不同的宗教，我们在之前的播客中讨论过这一点，是的……
And what you have there is a sense that because Christ has offered the perfect sacrifice to God, there is therefore no more need for the sacrifices that Judean custom prescribes should be done in the temple. And that furthermore, the temple has been replaced by the body of the Christian faithful. The church is now the new temple. And these are ideas that are current before the sack of the temple. So the fact that the temple is then destroyed seems to the emergent Christian community absolute evidence that this perspective is correct and that God has found the temple establishment, he's weighed it in the balance and found it wanting. And that is why in the long run, the writings of Josephus survive. Because of the christians they're preserved by christians because they're so important to for backing up the kind of christian idea that basically the church has replaced the temple as the focus of of god's um care so hold on tom let's say that uh you know constantine the great um he is one of a number of well people they are auditioning different religions we've talked about this in previous podcasts yeah you know it could have been isis it could have been
本可以是伊西斯（Isis），本可以是赫拉克勒斯（Heracles），谁知道呢，无敌太阳神（Sol Invictus）。如果是其中之一，你是不是基本上在说约瑟夫斯会被遗忘，因为他将失去用处？我们也不会做这期关于犹太起义的播客，因为犹太起义就像其他许多行省起义一样，会被彻底、完全地遗忘。我的意思是，在君士坦丁皈依之前，约瑟夫斯就已经被基督教作家们使用了。所以这是可能的，我的意思是，从某种意义上说，它印证了戏剧性，也就是基督徒理解历史进程的方式。所以，我认为这基本上就是约瑟夫斯的文本能够进入中世纪并进入现代的原因。如果我们没有约瑟夫斯，我们对当时的背景将一无所知。那么，还有另一个群体……很好，但还有另一个群体可能会记住……
heracles who knows solon victus had it been one of those are you basically saying josephus would be forgotten because he wouldn't be useful we wouldn't be doing this podcast about the jewish revolt because the jewish revolt like so many other provincial revolts, would just have been completely and utterly forgotten. I mean, Josephus is being used by Christian writers before Constantine converts. So it's possible that, I mean, in a sense, it kind of backs up drama, which is how Christians understand the rolling through of history. So that, I think, is basically why the text of Joseph into the uh into the middle ages and then into the modern period um and if we didn't have josephus we'd know almost nothing about the context so what about there's another group fine but there's another group of people who might remember
赫拉克勒斯知道索伦·维克图斯，如果它是其中之一的话，你基本上是在说约瑟夫斯会被遗忘，因为他没有用，我们也就不会做这个关于犹太起义的播客了，因为犹太起义就像其他许多地方起义一样，会被完全彻底地遗忘。我的意思是，在君士坦丁皈依之前，约瑟夫斯就被基督教作家所引用。所以这是可能的，我的意思是，从某种意义上说，它有点支持了戏剧性，也就是基督徒理解历史进程的方式。所以，我认为，这基本上就是约瑟夫斯的作品进入中世纪然后进入现代时期的原因，嗯，如果我们没有约瑟夫斯，我们对当时的背景将一无所知，那么还有一个群体，好吧，但还有另一群人可能会记住
it which who are the jews themselves or the rather the judeans so well yeah this okay so first of all i mean there's so many questions here. What happens to the Judeans? Are they all still in Judea? Secondly, at what point do they become Jews? And thirdly, what role does this event have in their kind of sense of themselves and their unique history. The destruction of the temple and the annihilation of Jerusalem is, I mean, it's hard to think of a more shocking, destabilizing event for a devout Judean. Because without the temple, you can't offer the sacrifices that that are mandated in torah so what do you do there's there's you know there's plenty of evidence that lots of them abandon their faith in their belief in the benignity of of their god essentially that that you know if they can't practice you know
犹太人本身，或者更准确地说是犹太山区居民……好吧，这，首先，我的意思是这里有太多问题了。犹太人发生了什么？他们是不是都还留在犹太地？其次，他们在什么时间点成为了犹太人？第三，在他们对自身以及独特历史的某种认知中，这一事件起到了什么作用？圣殿的毁灭和耶路撒冷的消灭，我的意思是，对一个虔诚的犹太人来说，很难想象还有比这更具冲击力、更具颠覆性的事件了。因为没有了圣殿，你就无法献上《托拉》所要求的祭祀，那你该怎么办呢？有，你知道的，有充分的证据表明，他们中的许多人放弃了他们的信仰，放弃了对他们的神之仁慈的信仰，本质上就是说，你知道的，如果他们无法实践，你知道的，
they the temple is no longer there they just give it up completely but also do they feel let down abandoned do you completely abandon yes absolutely but because this has happened before so you know there are there are there are scriptures and writings written in the wake of the sack of jerusalem by the babylonians yeah kind of try to make sense of this and to explain it. And because you have the body of Torah still, that for Judeans who want to stay true to their traditions provides them with more than a life raft. I mean, it's something absolutely see where they can cling on to what happens over the course of the decades that follow and the centuries is that the the authority that had previously been invested in the temple authorities comes to be invested in
圣殿不复存在了，他们就彻底放弃了。但话说回来，他们是否感到被辜负、被抛弃？你是否彻底放弃了？是的，绝对有，但这以前也发生过，所以，你知道的，有一些经文和著作是在巴比伦人洗劫耶路撒冷之后写下来的，它们试图理解这一事件并对其进行解释。由于你仍然拥有《托拉》这部经典，对于那些想要忠于自己传统的犹太人来说，这给他们提供的不仅仅是一根救命稻草。我的意思是，这绝对是他们能够紧紧抓住的东西。在接下来的几十年和几个世纪里发生的情况是，以前赋予圣殿当局的权力，现在开始赋予给
in teachers who are associated with institutions called synagogues. So these are places beyond Jerusalem where you gather to, you know, the Torah scrolls are kept and so on like that. And there's one place in particular, a place called Yavne, which is now a suburb of Tel Aviv, where these teachers, rabbis, seem to have particularly congregated.
那些与被称为犹太会堂（synagogues）的机构相关的老师们。所以这些是耶路撒冷之外的地方，你聚集在那里，你知道的，《托拉》卷轴存放在那里等等。有一个地方特别引人注目，一个叫做亚夫涅（Yavne）的地方，现在是特拉维夫的一个郊区，这些老师，即拉比们，似乎特别聚集在那里。
And there is this very strong tradition that this is basically where what we might call rabbinical Judaism, the form of Judaism that is practiced now by people that we would call Jews, it's where it really puts down roots. Now, obviously, for the rabbis, the memory of the destruction of Jerusalem is always there, but they don't remember it as Josephus had done, or indeed as Christians do, as an event of history. They see it as a kind of cosmic calamity that transcends history. And so you do have Vespasian and Titus do feature, say, in the Talmud, which is this kind of great corpus of writings that emerge through the 5th, 6th, 7th century. So there's a legend that one of the rabbis, a guy called Yohanan ben Zakkai, he escapes the siege of Jerusalem in a coffin.
有一个非常强烈的传统认为，我们称之为拉比犹太教（rabbinical Judaism）的东西——也就是现在被我们称为犹太人的人所实践的犹太教形式——基本上就是在那里扎根的。当然，对于拉比们来说，关于耶路撒冷毁灭的记忆是一直存在的，但他们并不像约瑟夫斯那样，或者像基督徒那样，把它记作一个历史事件。他们把它看作一种超越历史的宇宙灾难。所以维斯帕星和提图斯确实在《塔木德》中出现过，这是一部在公元5世纪、6世纪、6世纪到7世纪逐渐成型的伟大著作合集。因此有一个传说，说其中一位拉比，一个叫约哈南·本·扎凯（Yohanan ben Zakkai）的人，他装在棺材里逃出了耶路撒冷的围城。
And he gets brought to Vespasian, who in this version is leading the siege rather than Titus. And he gets out of the coffin and he hails Vespasian as the king of the world. And at that point, news arrives that Nero is dead. And so Vespasian grants Yohanan ben Zakkai and all the other rabbis the right to go and set up their base in Yavne. And you can see there a kind of distorted memory of Josephus' writings. It was really interesting. Even more, Titus is commemorated as a monstrous figure. So there is a story told that his plan when he captured the temple had been
他被带到了维斯帕星面前，在这个版本中，是维斯帕星而不是提图斯在指挥围城。他从棺材里爬出来，欢呼维斯帕星为世界之王。就在那时，尼禄已死的消息传来了。于是维斯帕星授予约哈南·本·扎凯以及所有其他拉比在亚夫涅建立基地的权利。你可以在其中看到一种对约瑟夫斯著作的扭曲记忆。这真的很奇妙。更绝的是，提图斯被当作一个怪物来纪念。所以有一个故事说，他攻占圣殿时的计划是
that he was going to go into the Holy of Holies, so the most sacred place, not just in the temple, but in the world, and he was going to have sex with a prostitute there on a kind of rolled out Torah scroll. Oh my word. Yeah, I mean, the kind of ultimate blasphemy. And when he gets in there, he stabs the curtain that veils the Holy of Holies and it starts to bleed. And Titus thinks that he's killed the Judean God. And so therefore he doesn't need to go ahead with his blasphemy,
他要进入至圣所，也就是不仅在圣殿中、而且在世界上最神圣的地方，他要在那里展开的一卷《托拉》卷轴上与一个妓女发生性关系。天哪。是的，我的意思是，这是终极的亵渎。当他进去时，他刺了一下遮蔽至圣所的帘子，帘子开始流血。提图斯以为他杀死了犹太人的神。因此，他觉得没必要继续进行他的亵渎行为了，
but this doesn't preserve him because the rabbis say a little gnat, as he was sailing back to Rome, flew up his nose all the way through his sinuses, up into his brain, and started gnawing on his brain for seven years and drove him mad until he died. And he's now in hell. And every day he is incinerated and his ashes are cast on the sea, and then he's reconstituted. And so the process goes on. So this is clearly not history, but it's tribute to the kind of, you know, the potent role that the destruction of the temple continues to play in the imaginings of both Jews and Christians.
但这并没有保护他，因为拉比们说，当他乘船返回罗马时，一只小蚊子飞进了他的鼻子，穿过鼻窦直达大脑，开始啃咬他的大脑长达七年之久，把他折磨疯了，直到他死去。他现在在地狱里。每天他都被焚烧，骨灰被撒向大海，然后他又重组。这个过程就这样循环往复。所以这显然不是历史，但这证明了圣殿的毁灭在犹太人和基督徒的想象中继续发挥着的强大作用。
So you've got all that way. You've got the Flavian propaganda. You've got the Christian idea that the destruction of Jerusalem shows the truth of the fact that the church has replaced the temple. And you have the Jewish, the rabbinical idea that the wellsprings of the study of Torah as it's practiced now and of the Talmud and so on is also rooted in the events of this great revolt, that you can see why it's such a kind of seismically important event in history. But you can also see why it's really, really difficult
所以你有这一切。你有弗拉维王朝的宣传。你有基督徒的观点，即耶路撒冷的毁灭证明了教会已经取代圣殿这一事实。你还有犹太人的、拉比的观点，即现在实行的《托拉》研究和《塔木德》等等的源泉也根植于这场伟大起义的事件中，你可以看出为什么它在历史上具有如此震撼人心的重要性。但你也可以看出为什么它真的非常非常困难
to get back beyond all those perspectives and to see what might actually have happened. All right, Tom. I think you should, though. Have a go. And let's say it's very, very speculative. But what do you think? So, okay, we can't know, we can't tell all this, but do you think it really was just a common or garden provincial tax revolt? That the Flavians and then the Christians and the Jews all exaggerated? Or do you think this was something more large scale, more serious? Right. So it's clear that there are, as I said, there are trends in Judean culture, in Judean society
去超越所有这些视角，去看看当时实际可能发生了什么。好了，汤姆。不过我想你应该试一试。就当作是非常非常推测性的。但你觉得呢？所以，好吧，我们不可能知道，我们无法讲述这一切，但你认为这真的只是一场普通得不能再普通的省级税务起义吗？是弗拉维王朝、后来的基督徒和犹太人都夸大了？还是你认为这是一场更大规模、更严重的事件？好。很显然，正如我所说，犹太文化和犹太社会中存在着一些趋势
that lead Judeans to resent Roman rule. Yeah. And these are cast in theological terms you know the romans are idolaters pagans um you know they will be destroyed at the end of days these are traditions that are kind of circulating bubbling around the idea of the messiah is there it is present it's all kind of part of it um against that it's it's evident that lots of judeans and particularly jerusalem itself had had absolutely flourished under roman rule jerusalem has been very strongly favored by the by a succession of emperors and Roman rulers and Roman governors. They have been treated with absolute kind of kid gloves.
导致犹太人对罗马统治心怀怨恨。是的。这些都是用神学语言表达的，你知道的，罗马人是偶像崇拜者、异教徒，嗯，你知道的，他们将在末日被消灭，这些是流传的、沸腾的传统，关于弥赛亚的想法就在那里，它是存在的，这都是其中的一部分，嗯。与此相对的是，显而易见的是，许多犹太人，尤其是耶路撒冷本身，在罗马统治下绝对是繁荣昌盛的。耶路撒冷一直受到历代皇帝、罗马统治者和罗马总督的强烈青睐。他们受到了绝对娇生惯养般的对待。
There's a huge sensitivity towards Judean scruples, theological scruples, cultic scruples. So, you know, for instance, there's a soldier who bears his arse during the Passover. He's executed. Another one desecrates a scroll of Torah. He's also executed. There are the coinage bears no Roman coinage. You know, there's a kind of concentrated effort not to put things on this coinage that would offend Judean sensibilities. And, you know, a lot of Judeans recognize, and, you know, there are a lot of Judeans outside Judea,
对于犹太人的顾忌，神学上的顾忌，宗教仪式上的顾忌，有着巨大的敏感度。所以，你知道，例如，有一个士兵在逾越节期间露出屁股。他被处决了。另一个士兵亵渎了《托拉》卷轴。他也一样被处决了。铸造的硬币上没有罗马硬币的痕迹。你知道，人们有一种集中努力，不在这些硬币上印上会触犯犹太人情感的东西。而且，你知道，许多犹太人认识到，并且，你知道，有许多犹太人在犹太地之外，
in Alexandria, in Rome, they're the dog that doesn't bark. You know, they do not join in the revolt. And they can recognize that Roman rule is kind of good. You know, it's good for prosperity. You can travel there. You can, you know. Good for trade. Good for trade. Globalization has its benefits. You know, as in globalization today, there are people at the bottom who tend to resent it. But, you know, there's absolutely a case for saying that, you know, most Judeans can recognize that Roman rule has been good for the temple, good for Jerusalem, good for their standard of living. And that the Romans basically have backed them backed them say against the sumerians now one of the complications is that the the troops that the governors use are probably sumerian so when gessius floris the procurator whose exact tax exactions kind of initiates the uh the explosion The soldiers that he has are probably
在亚历山大里亚，在罗马，他们就像那只不叫的狗。你知道的，他们没有加入起义。他们能够认识到罗马统治在某种程度上是好的。你知道，这对繁荣有好处。你可以在那里旅行，你可以，你知道的。对贸易有好处。对贸易有好处。全球化有其好处。你知道，就像今天的全球化一样，社会底层总有一些人对此心怀不满，但是，你知道，绝对有理由说，大多数犹太人都能认识到，罗马统治对圣殿、对耶路撒冷、对他们的生活水平都有好处。而且罗马人基本上是在支持他们，支持他们对抗叙利亚人。现在，复杂的事情之一是，总督们使用的军队很可能是叙利亚人，所以当盖西乌斯·弗洛里斯（Gessius Florus）——这位其苛捐杂税引发了这场大爆发的代理总督——
Sumerians. So they're not Romans. They're serving the Roman army, but they're Sumerians. And so there is that sense of a kind of a religious and ethnic rivalry that is, it's a kind of a fire starter on the bonfire. So that's a kind of crucial part of it, I think. So I think you could say there's nothing inherent, I think, within the currents of Judean society that made it inevitable. And the further evidence for that is that actually Judeans had lived very, you know, I mean, not exactly contentedly, but they had, you know, they'd lived under the Persians, they'd lived under the Greeks, they'd been the bust up, you know, with Julius Maccabeus, that's true. But then under Rome, again, there hadn't been, you know, there'd been no kind of particular disturbances. And so I think that that implies that the events are, the revolt is set in train by contingent events. And I think essentially the contingency is the fact that Nero needs the money. I think it's a kind of ripple effect from the fire of Rome.
他手下的士兵很可能是叙利亚人。所以他们不是罗马人。他们在为罗马军队服役，但他们是叙利亚人。因此，有一种宗教和种族竞争的感觉，这就像是篝火上的一点火星。所以这是其中一个至关重要的部分，我认为。因此我认为你可以说，在犹太社会的发展潮流中，并没有什么内在的东西使这一切成为必然。这方面的进一步证据是，实际上犹太人在历史上一直生活得很，你知道的——虽然不是完全满足，但他们确实，你知道的——他们在波斯人统治下生活过，在希腊人统治下生活过，他们曾与犹大·马加比（Julius Maccabeus）爆发过冲突，这是真的。但后来在罗马统治下，同样，也没有发生过，你知道的，没有什么特别的骚乱。因此我认为这暗示着这些事件、这场起义是由偶然事件引发的。而我认为本质上的偶然因素是尼禄需要钱这一事实。我认为这是罗马大火产生的一种连锁反应。
And it's the fact that the Judeans, for once, because Gessius Florus, his tax collector, has gone there and he has the personal backing of Nero, they can't appeal over his head either to Herod Agrippa, the local king, or to the governor in Syria. And I think that basically that's the problem, that resentment against the taxics' actions result in the massacre of the Sumerians, the Sumerian garrison in Jerusalem. And that then having done that, they're then, you know, they're stuck on the on the down escalator, which then starts to accelerate when they wipe out the legions that have come from Syria. And then, you know, there's no way back, really. Okay. And obviously, then you end up with this event that sort of retrospectively becomes a complete landmark, both forianity and i guess for judaism yeah and so people have asked um you know is this a bog standard provincial revolt i mean on one level clearly not because it it's still remembered to this day for the reasons we've gone in yeah but in another sense it kind of
事实是，犹太人们破例一次——因为盖西乌斯·弗洛里斯的税吏去了那里，并且有尼禄的个人支持——他们无法越过他向当地国王希律·阿格里帕（Herod Agrippa）或叙利亚总督上诉。我认为这基本上就是问题所在，对税务暴行的怨恨导致了耶路撒冷的叙利亚人、叙利亚驻军遭到屠杀。既然他们已经这么做了，他们就陷入了，你知道的，他们被困在了下行的自动扶梯上，当他们消灭了从叙利亚赶来的军团时，这种下行开始加速。然后，你知道的，真的没有回头路了。好的。显而易见，最后你会遇到这样一个事件，它事后来看变成了一个完整的里程碑，对基督教和我想对犹太教来说都是如此。所以人们会问，嗯，这到底是不是一场标准得不能再标准的行省起义？我的意思是，从一个层面来看显然不是，因为它直到今天仍被人们铭记，原因我们已经讨论过了。但在另一个意义上，它其实又
is really i mean if we had a josephus to describe say buddhica's revolt where likewise you have you know a war is is you know of eradication is practiced against the druids the druids are cast as people you know far more than that that say that you know judean priesthood or the rabbis are the romans never attempt to extirpate the judean priests they never attempt to extirpate the rabbis they do attempt to extirpate the druids and against the backdrop of 69 you know the year of the four emperors yeah this where it seems that the roman empire is collapsing you have very kind of similar apocalyptic movements elsewhere in the empire so you in in um in lyon in gaul you have um a local gaul who declares that he's he's a god and he's come to rule the world. He ends up being
确实是。我的意思是，如果我们有一个约瑟夫斯来描述布狄卡（Boudicca）的起义，同样，你也会发现一场针对德鲁伊的歼灭战。德鲁伊被塑造成这样一群人，比起犹太祭司或拉比来说，罗马人从未企图根除犹太祭司，他们从未企图根除拉比，但他们确实企图根除德鲁伊。在公元69年（四帝之年）的背景下，在这个罗马帝国似乎正在崩溃的时期，你在帝国的其他地方也看到了非常相似的末日运动。所以在高卢的里昂，有一个当地的高卢人，他宣称自己是神，是来统治世界的。他最终被
put to death. And on the Roman frontier, the Rhine frontier, you have a priestess who is apparently installed in a tower beyond the Rhine, preaching the doom of Rome and the fact that all the legionary bases will be wiped out. And again, you have this interface between provincial revolt and kind of apocalyptic visions. There's nothing distinctively unusual about what's happening in Judea. It's just the long-term ripple effect. But let's take this back then to where we started there is one very distinctive thing which is that what happened in the judean revolt was predicted by our top geopolitical pundit from the very beginning of this story jesus christ in the gospel of saint luke now tom what is going on there why has it been so why does it appear to have been so accurately predicted in in luke's gospel or is there some there some other story there that I'm not getting because I'm not familiar with this stuff?
处死了。在罗马边境，莱茵河边境，有一个女祭司，显然驻扎在莱茵河外的一座高塔上，宣扬罗马的末日即将来临，所有的军团基地都将被消灭。再次，你看到了行省起义与某种末日愿景之间的交集。犹太地发生的事情并没有什么特别不同寻常的地方。这只是长期的连锁反应。但让我们回到我们最初的话题，有一个非常独特的事情，那就是犹太起义中发生的事情，从这个故事一开始就被我们的顶级地平说/地缘政治专家——圣经《路加福音》中的耶稣基督所预言了。那么，汤姆，这到底是怎么回事？为什么在《路加福音》中它显得如此准确地被预言了？还是说其中有别的我不太了解的故事，因为我对这些东西不熟悉？
Well, I mean, it depends if you think that Jesus is a true prophet. Maybe he foresaw what was going to happen, and that's an authentic record of what he foresaw. Or maybe he extrapolated from what he wanted to happen you know there's there's clearly a lot of uh apocalyptic language um in the gospels yeah uh and so the idea that the temple might be destroyed um is pretty important to um how christians you know even in the very early decades uh are seeing god's purpose or perhaps it's a retrospective prophecy that's attributed to him uh and and that that particular passage is written after the destruction of the temple i mean all these all these arguments have been made so we just don't know yeah i so one other thing i Yeah. So one last thing that we should probably just mention is Masada.
好吧，我的意思是，这取决于你是否认为耶稣是一位真正的先知。也许他预见到了将要发生的事情，那是对他的预见的真实记录。或者也许他是根据他希望发生的事情进行了外推，你知道的，福音书中显然有很多末日语言，所以圣殿可能会被毁灭的想法，对于基督徒来说——甚至在最初的几十年里——如何看待神的旨意是非常重要的。或者这可能是一个事后才归功于他的预言，而那段特定的经文是在圣殿毁灭之后写下来的。我的意思是，所有这些论点都被人提出过，所以我们只是无从得知。是的。所以还有一件事，是的。我们可能应该顺便提一下马萨达（Masada）。
Because the destruction of the temple has always played quite an important role in the way that Christians have seen the world. Recently, the story of Masada has begun to play quite a significant role in the way that maybe not Jews, but Israelis. Well, because of being embattled, being surrounded, the self-sacrificial nature of the story, you can completely understand why, how in the 20th century, Israelis would take up that as a kind of founding myth. Yeah. So this story in the wake of the foundation of Israel becomes politically incredibly important. And there's this kind of interface between politics and archaeology in Israel that you get. So the great excavation at Masada took place in 1963, 1965,
因为圣殿的毁灭在基督徒看世界的方式中一直扮演着相当重要的角色。最近，马萨达的故事开始在某种程度上扮演非常重要的角色，也许不是对犹太人而言，而是对以色列人而言。好吧，由于处于四面楚歌、被包围的境地，以及故事中表现出的自我牺牲精神，你完全可以理解为什么、以及在20世纪以色列人会如何将这一点作为一种建国神话接受下来。是的。因此，在以色列建国之后，这个故事在政治上变得极其重要。在以色列，政治和考古学之间存在着这样一种交集。因此，马萨达的大规模考古发掘发生在1963年到1965年，
with an archaeologist called Yigal Yadin, who was also the former military chief of staff. And so he felt, you know, just as Israel was surrounded by enemies, so also the rebels on the mountaintop of Masada had been surrounded by enemies. And this is an idea that then gets passed on to Moshe Dayan. And he has a kind of swearing in ritual for soldiers in, I can't remember what it is, one of the divisions of the Israeli army who've kind of graduated and passed their training, that they do, you know, they graduate on the summit of Masada
由考古学家伊加尔·雅丁（Yigal Yadin）主持，他也是前军事参谋长。因此他觉得，正如以色列被敌人包围一样，马萨达山顶上的叛军也曾被敌人包围。这个想法后来传给了摩西·达扬（Moshe Dayan）。他在以色列军队的某个师——我记不清具体是哪个了——中为那些毕业并通过训练的士兵举行了一种宣誓仪式，他们，你知道的，在马萨达山顶毕业，
and they declare that Masada shall not fall again. So this is, you's very it's been very very important to to Israeli self-image I mean inevitably as with almost every other aspect of this story it's it's probably not quite what it seems because as I said just see the only account we have of this episode is written by Josephus. And he had clearly, not only had he not been there for the siege, but he'd never been to Masada. His account of what was on Masada doesn't correspond to what the archaeology shows. And in fact, the idea that it was rebels, people who were committed to fighting the Romans, camped out on Masada, seems almost to be the reverse of the truth. Because actually what you have on
并宣誓马萨达绝不再失守。所以这对以色列人的自我形象来说非常非常重要。我的意思是，不可避免地，就像这个故事几乎所有其他方面一样，它可能并不完全像表面上看起来的那样，因为正如我所说，关于这个插曲我们唯一的记载是由约瑟夫斯写的。不仅他显然没有亲历那场围城战，而且他从未去过马萨达。他对马萨达上有什么东西的描述与考古发现并不相符。事实上，认为那是叛军——那些致力于与罗马人战斗的人——驻扎在马萨达的山顶上，这种想法几乎与事实完全相反。因为实际上你在
the top of Masada are people who fled Rome. They fled confrontation with the Romans. If they'd wanted to fight the Romans, they wouldn't be up on that mountaintop. And probably by the time that the Romans get there, they've been there for kind of, you know, eight years, pretty harmless. I mean, they're not doing any harm, but they, you know, they are standing outside the frameworks of roman power and so therefore they they constitute rebels in the eyes of the romans yeah uh and they they send a single legion it seems to i mean basically it's probably a kind of you know to to keep keep the soldiers on their toes it's a pretty routine policing operation and they seem to have stormed it pretty easily so it's almost certainly not the um the heroic tale of resistance that uh that josephus and um you know current israeli yeah perspective would have it so hollywood will
马萨达山顶上发现的是那些逃离罗马的人。他们逃避了与罗马人的对抗。如果他们想与罗马人战斗，他们就不会跑到那个山顶上去。而且可能当罗马人到达那里时，他们已经在那里呆了大约，你知道的，八年了，基本上是无害的。我的意思是，他们没有造成任何伤害，但是，你知道的，他们站在罗马权力框架之外，因此在罗马人眼中他们构成了叛军。是的，他们派出了一个军团，似乎是为了——基本上这可能是一种，你知道的，为了让士兵保持警惕，这是一次相当常规的警务行动，而且他们似乎非常容易地就攻克了它。所以它几乎肯定不是约瑟夫斯和当前以色列人的视角所宣称的那种英雄抵抗传奇，所以好莱坞
not be getting in touch with you tom for um well script writing advice and probably not forthcoming masada films if there are any probably but you know but i mean it's a kind of you know it's a it is of course you know a tragic and terrible story because yeah you know you don't have to be a rebel for it you know they were clearly wiped out very bloodily and it's a kind of horrible story okay well um uh that as usual turned into into a much bigger story than we thought it would. So I hope you've enjoyed these episodes on the Jews versus Romans. Actually, Tom, this is one last thing., if you want to call the Judeans the Jews, I mean, you know, why not? There's nothing to stop you. I just think that using better to think of them rebelling as provincials than as people who are inspired by a religion. Okay.
不会找你，汤姆，来寻求剧本创作建议了，而且可能也不会有什么即将上映的马萨达电影，如果有的话可能也没有。但是，你知道，但这是一种，你知道的，它当然是一个悲惨而可怕的故事，因为，你知道的，你不需要成为一个叛军就会遭遇这种事，他们显然被极其血腥地消灭了，这是一个可怕的故事。好吧，嗯，像往常一样，这演变成了一个比我们想象的要大得多的故事。所以希望你们喜欢这些关于犹太人对阵罗马人的剧集。事实上，汤姆，还有最后一件事，如果你想把犹太山区居民称为犹太人，我的意思是，为什么不呢？没有什么能阻止你。我只是觉得，把他们视为行省居民造反，要比把他们视为受某种宗教启发的人造反，更能让人理解。好吧。
Fine. Thank you very much, Tom. That was an absolute panoramic, brilliant narrative. Very enjoyable. And you can go and have a rest now. Thank you very much for listening and goodbye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
很好。非常感谢你，汤姆。这是一个全景式的、极其精彩的叙事。非常引人入胜。你现在可以去休息了。非常感谢大家的收听，再见。拜拜。拜拜。
Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家剧集、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。
And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家剧集以及提前购买现场演出门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。